So once we get a client, what's our process from there?
What's the first thing that we do with the client?
We sign the contract.
What's the first thing that we do from there?
Yeah, we sign the contract, get the credit card,
get a credit card authorization, then run the credit card.
Make sure that it goes through.
We just ran the credit card.
We just did the pre-authorization.
But do we send out an email?
Do we schedule a phone call?
What does our next step look like to set those expectations?
Yeah.
So when I'm closing the deal, I like to also add in expectations
and how everything will work.
I include that into the closing call.
And then I, well, the contract, the card, whatever that part we already said.
And then I send them an email with things that I need from them.
That I do have a template, but sometimes it depends on the business owner
because for example, we need to set up a GMB or photos.
It's just a list of things that I need from the owner.
And I include that in the email.
It's like a welcome email where you get them a little pumped up
and you ask them information that you need to get started,
like phone number and stuff like that.
All the things that you need in order to make the website for them
and literally make the whole project.
So as soon as the deal is closed, then we just let them know,
hey, you're going to get an email from me.
I'm going to ask you for a couple of things.
I need you to give us this information.
And then from there, we can get things started.
So that's step number one is an email goes out.
Yeah.
So email goes out.
What happens after the email?
So after that, I just wait for them to respond with the information.
And then after they send that over, I don't really contact them
until everything is done.
And then when everything is built out,
which usually doesn't take us more than a week,
less than a week usually,
then I update them and tell them, hey, we're all done with the site
and just kind of give them an update.
And then after that, it depends on the client, to be honest.
Does the update happen on the phone?
Does it happen on email?
Does it happen on text?
See, that also depends because some clients will not answer their phones
and they just text me back.
They're like, hey, what's up?
And that way, I just usually send them a text.
Most of the time, I like to call them or email them is even better.
That way, I don't know.
I just like having the record, but it does depend on the client.
After that, yeah, I just check in with them.
And obviously, another thing that you'll do to contact them is
after that is built, you want to test the site,
which also that would also mean, obviously,
that you're going to call them when you're testing the Legion site.
So that's another way to kind of check in on the first week.
So the first week, you talk to them often.
You send them the email.
You call them to test the site.
You call them or text them or email them to let them know, hey, this is finished.
And yeah, after that, I check in with them every month.